ben shapiro is editor-in-chief of daly
wire comm been good to see you tonight
thank you for being here you wrote about
this you talked about it on your podcast
today what do you see as the hypocrisy
in the coverage on this story
Namie was pretty astonishing so several
years ago obviously when the media
started to delve into all of the sex
abuse allegations against the Catholic
Church there's a great deal of
enthusiasm I think rightly so in the
press for investigating all of that but
now that Pope Francis is at the head of
the church and they're like Pope Francis
more than they like Pope Benedict and
the left-wing press suddenly they have
to rush to Pope Francis's defense over
these allegations so the New York Times
ran one of the worst headlines I've ever
seen today talking about how as the
allegations against Pope Francis mount
conservatives pounced conservatives
house conservatives pouncing go ahead
then I just want to put on the screen
for everybody to say that there I mean
it's an amazing accusation that this
story is not actually serious
allegations levied at the head of the
Catholic Church by other lead members of
the Catholic Church over a cover-up of
sex abuse of children now the real
stories that conservatives might use
this to go get an icon for the political
left it just demonstrates that for the
left it does make you wonder whether
it's an actual priority to protect
children or whether the higher priority
is to protect the politics that they see
as imperative yeah I mean it's pretty
it's pretty unbelievable and I just want
to point out that they they sort of
soften the New York Times stop in that
headline between the online version and
the newspaper version the original
newspaper version said Francis takes the
high road as conservatives pounced
taking criticisms public and then I want
to play a bit of an interview with
Cardinal blaze sue pitch thank you sue
pitch which is also rightly getting
attention for what he's said in here
which which could have easily just been
blasted watch this the Pope has a bigger
agenda he's got to get on with other
things of talking about the environment
and protecting migrants and carrying on
the work of the church we're not going
to go down a rabbit hole on this Wow
we're not going down that rabbit hole I
mean has he's seen the stories that were
published about the Pennsylvania diocese
and what they did to these children how
exactly is what sue pitch just said not
the headline on every major paper in the
United States the only possible
shanell is that a lot of members the
press actually agree that when it comes
to choosing between leftist politics in
the Catholic Church and protecting
children leftist politics have to take
the center stage the reality is that it
can you imagine if Pope Benedict had
said anything like this you know six
seven years ago when he was the head of
the Catholic Church and when these
allegations were in full swing against
the Boston archdiocese of course it
would have been the end of the world and
it should be the end of the world
because when people in positions of
power are covering for institutional
disgusting and criminal behavior that
should be the end of the world
particularly when it's a religious
institution that is tasked with
presumably
God's Word on earth but instead the
press at least at the New York Times
seemed deeply concerned with protecting
Pope Francis from any and all comers
because they like Pope Francis and and
it's it's I've rarely seen a more
disgusting example and press behavior
than this it's truly is an amazing
amazing thing it is it's pretty
unbelievable and when you point out you
know the movie spotlight which got so
much attention which rightfully as you
say put a focus on what had been
happening for decades in the Boston
diocese and then you know the church's
defense you know which really was not
credible we now know because these
things are they go on a lot less than
they used to but I don't know that
that's really any comfort to anybody
because they shouldn't be happening at
all but it was like oh it was all
decades ago but now that you're learning
that that you know Cardinal Wuerl who's
still being discussed about whether or
not he should be able to maintain his
his position in Washington DC may have
known about these things and that Pope
Francis may have known about these
things the same people who were so hard
on the church when spotlight came out
and when those stories came to light
should be absolutely leading with these
stories and asking him these hard
questions and pressing people like sue
pitch I mean it's it's pretty
unbelievable I mean if Jesus had any
central teaching yeah it one of them was
that children are the most important to
be protected and it you know in Matthew
he says you know if you if you caused
any of the little ones to stumble you
should have a large millstone hung
around your neck and be drowned in the
depths of the sea again it's it's an
amazing thing and I think it goes to the
fact that when it was pope john paul ii
or what it was benedict then the press
didn't like those guys because those
guys were very conservative particularly
on social issues but because
Frances is I think in his essence a
Liberation Theology who believes a lot
of left-wing things about climate change
and redistribution of income and illegal
immigration they're going to protect him
from accusations from the so called
conservative wing of the church which
after all is basically just asking the
Pope to I don't know in force what seems
to me to be basic Catholic doctrine for
the past couple of thousand years and
one of the things that you know Pope
Francis said Who am I to judge when it
comes to gay priests and he was lauded
for that for sort of opening up the
understanding of that and I think one
thing we have to be very very clear on
is that you know to be gay is not to be
a pedophile we're talking about criminal
pedophile behavior here and I think
everybody on both sides of the
conservative liberal argument ought to
be able to get on the same side that
everybody is against criminal behavior
in pedophilia right when you are
treating the the pedophilia of children
and the the mistreatment of children
abuse of children as a political
football in or protect your guy I would
suggest that you're the evil one in the
scenario ben shapiro
thank you very much Ben good to see you
tonight great piece today